so there's a new liberal narrative
Brewing despite blue States crumbling
into crime-infested no-go zones the
media wants you to think that it's the
red states that are terrible
CNBC is getting blasted over an article
that names Texas and Florida as the
worst states to live and work citing
laws protecting unborn life so-called
targeting of lgdbq people and the
state's issues with inclusiveness
strange not a peep about how left-wing
policies are causing folks to leave
liberal areas and droves Jessica we'll
go to you first
do you really think that these states
Texas and Florida are bad places to live
everyone's moving there a lot of people
are moving there and I'm definitely not
going to try to sugarcoat The Exodus
from these big blue States and we're
really suffering in terms of tax revenue
a lot of rich people leaving a lot of
Corporations have left but I do think
that making a decision of where you want
to live as a single person especially as
a family is a really big one you're
going to be looking at all sorts of
factors you're going to be considering
what the education system looks like
you're going to be thinking about what
kind of access to health care if you
have a daughter that you're going there
a lot of people have said in terms of
picking where you go to university for
instance if you're going to end up in a
state where you could become pregnant
let's say 20 years old and you're not
going to have access to reproductive
Health Care there that does matter
climate change matters I mean we're
seeing record temperatures going on
right now Texas been under a heat
advisory forever in Florida they had a
record on Monday 109 in Miami where a
lot of people move to 16 days in a row
of at least 105. at least they have
affordable energy
there was a study out from the Council
of Criminal Justice nonpartisan looked
at the data of 30 U.S cities including
La Philly Chicago
um New York the first half of this year
and the homicide rates have dropped by
over nine percent and now the homicide
rate in Miami is three times that of New
York City with a GOP mayor who thinks
that he's going to be president of the
United States of America and a GOP
governor who also thinks he's going to
be president of the United States of
America so go Blue States was so high
when you get that high it has to come
down at some point but anyway does it
yes I thought in Biden's America The
Killing never stops well it seems that
way
correct oh
this is why the United States is great
though it's federalism Dana oh that's
interesting it's a Terrain for beta
testing right every state can can try
out stuff they should be trying out more
stuff there should be Sanctuary cities
for people who want to have guns right
you come here with your gun we'll take
like we have Sanctuary City for illegal
acts so like why can't we have Sanctuary
cities for other things how about
Sanctuary City up for not paying taxes I
mean there should be comparisons to
things called Delaware yes exactly but
the weirdest thing is at the same time
this stuff this stuff came out there was
a study that CNN was promoting and I
don't even know if it was CNN's original
stuff saying mass shooting among blacks
has occur where there are more blacks
did you see this and they blamed it on
structural racism there was not a shred
of evidence in there and it's like maybe
in these Urban dense areas
that should be factored in maybe move to
these you know small towns because guess
what that stuff doesn't happen in small
towns but the jobs aren't there yeah I
think that's going to change over time
people are working well more remote yeah
yeah Dana well I think that the people
who are moving to these states don't
watch CNBC right because here's some of
the criteria that CNBC use it wasn't can
you safely raise a child here but can
you get an abortion there it wasn't
um can you sue your employer it was can
you sue your employer for woke nonsense
it was more like do they ask for voter
ID as if that was like a bad thing they
asked um things like in Tennessee it's
hard to live in because the legislature
banned drag shows for children
why that's hard to live there but people
started voting with their feet during
covet but it's continued and I love the
experimentation especially when they
look at their paychecks and go whoa I
got more money in my pocket that's true
Judge Jeanine you know they didn't even
try to be fair in this thing the 10
states and yeah I agree with Dana I mean
you know it was all about voting
reproductive freedoms inclusiveness it
had nothing to do with the economic
conditions by now safety Free Speech
free religion all that stuff no that was
not part of it but every one of the
states that they say are the top 10
worst they're all Republican they didn't
even try to throw one blue one in there
you know but the truth is this the top
10 states or people are fleeing 9 out of
ten or democrat States and they're
fleeing for a lot of reasons and it is a
lot of because of the taxes and because
of the fact that there is no safety
there so you know I think the criteria
was ridiculous and I think uh that they
obviously made a big mistake what I
thought was interesting also when I was
doing the research on this in Moscow
Idaho just today they that town had to
pay three hundred thousand dollars to
three Catholics uh who apparently were
arrested during a religious service
outside and they weren't wearing a mask
you know that's the kind of religious
freedom that's important too all right
Jessica oh for three today let's see if
she can turn it around in the next block
oh a John Kerry
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now